radio boulot l'eau les écoles l'égard
des sujets importants
cela fait déjà quelques jours que du
haut de ses 21 ans dylan parcourent les
rues de son village d'à peine 500 âmes à
la rencontre des habitants
le jeune homme se lance dans le bain des
municipales en présentant une liste dans
sa commune
quand j'ai appris que le maire sortant
de certains viendrait pas au mois de
décembre je me suis dit qu'on n'avait
pas laissé la commune à l'abandon sans
conseil municipal sans conseiller la
placer sous tutelle de la préfecture
alors j'ai réfléchi et c'est puis j'ai
décidé de porter ma candidature pour ça
il me fallait des gens expérimentés qui
avait déjà été conseiller municipaux par
le passé dylan a donc pris son bâton de
pèlerin et a vite trouvé dix colistiers
prêts à l'accompagner dans son projet
une équipe structurée où rien n'est
laissé au hasard tout en veillant à
prendre les gens de chacun des trois
villages qui composent la commune tout
en veillant à prendre des gens la
plupart des associations du village
l'association d'animation et loisirs
l'association de chasseurs
l'association des pompiers de village
pour que tout le monde soit représenté
le jour de notre tournage il n'y avait
aucune autre liste déclaré alors sa
candidature avait l'accent cauterets et
vaudrait tout le monde en parle
il faut dire que dylan tout le monde le
connaît depuis qu'il est petit c'est moi
ça fait quoi à 39 ans je suis saoul
ba devait y ait un très bel connaît bien
sa mère dans sa liste des hommes et des
femmes qui pourrait être pour certains
c'est par an voir ses grands parents
dylan a réussi à fédérer
à l'exemple de michel 59 ans cadre de
santé qui est venue le rejoindre
j'ai tout de suite dit oui parce que
d'autres pas ma fonction j'accompagne
beaucoup de jeunes et souvent des bas
les jeunes ils ont envie de rien
et savent pas quoi faire et là on a un
jeune qui en j donc moi j'ai envie de
l'aider
entre deux le jeune homme n'oublie pas
ses études il étudie le droit et
l'histoire par correspondance toujours
avec le même objectif que cela serve à
son village